breaking news overnight in some key
primary races for the democratic party
we begin in florida the former governor
charlie crist won the chance to
challenge the current gop governor ron
desantis of course desantis may become a
2024 presidential candidate and in new
york two powerhouse members of congress
were forced to face each other due to a
quirk of redistricting now one of them
out of a job scott mcfarland has more on
all of it on a very big primary night
we can make history and we will shock
the world democrats are putting their
bets on charlie crist a man who served
as a republican governor before
switching sides a decade ago governor
desantis only cares about the white
house he doesn't care about your house
hoping he can take on florida gop
governor ron desantis who's been on the
national stage taking on public school
agendas and going up against disney
leading up to a potential 2024
presidential run florida will be the
vanguard of freedom in this country
we have to get out and exercise our
right to vote meantime a former orlando
police chief appears set for a fight for
the florida u.s senate seat now occupied
by republican marco rubio the president
congresswoman val demings who is part of
the team leading the impeachment
proceedings against former president
trump has won that democratic nomination
when it comes to up to unpacking our
supreme court i'm going to stand up and
fight
in new york two major institutions of
congress were forced to face off
judiciary chair jerry nadler defeated
oversight committee chair carolyn
maloney which the party says is a major
loss of a powerhouse democrat due to a
newly redrawn congressional district and
two hours north in new york's hudson
valley a special election there may set
the road map for midterm strategies come
fall do you see outside interest coming
in here trying to fire up the voting
base
yeah jose without question
obviously everyone has a degree of
interest democrat pat ryan won last
night against republican mark molinaro
in the first competitive house election
since the u.s supreme court overturned
roe versus wade setting the stage for
what could be the last national test
case on whether abortion will drive
voters in november the foundations
of our democracy
were and remain under direct threat
because there was a special election
ryan will only serve in the seat for a
few months and have to run again in
november with the primary season largely
complete now we have roughly two months
till we find out if democrats have
momentum to preserve majorities in
congress
or if republicans are poised for victory
we are in this now
uh historically speaking it would appear
as though democrats are poised for big
losses based on everything you know
about politics however there are
different issues at play here what's
going to motivate voters in november
abortion rights women's reproductive
health writes
that's going to be a pivotal issue but
the question is will it be the
pivotal issue for voters that race last
night pat ryan in new york's 19th
district both candidates acknowledged
ryan ran on an abortion rights first
political platform question is nate
jamie and tony will that transcend the
kitchen table grocery price gas price
issue in every district across america
yeah most people vote with their wallet
they're not looking at the other issues
a lot of the time right about that you
know when you look at the biggest
takeaways from florida and new york i
think it's interesting that we're
talking about party establishment
not usually the biggest takeaway but it
seems like that's what happened here i
think democrats are waking up optimistic
thinking there may be some wiggle room
some opportunity here if they nominate
moderate mainstream some experienced
candidates against trump loyalists in
some districts across america the thing
is
there are a lot of variables and not a
lot of competitive races not a lot of
space right we'll find out over the next
76 days we will good to see you in
person yeah good to have you likewise
hudson valley native scott thank you